Now you're going to install
the Java Development Kit, but
a few quick notes before we begin.
So we've been calling
the Java Development Kit like a toolbox.
And what we mean by that is that the
Java Development Kit is software that
allows your computer to read and
work with the Java programming language.
This is sort of fundamentally
different than a software program,
because it's more like an upgrade for
your computer.
So as you're installing
the Java development kit,
it might seem a little bit intimidating.
But what I want to tell you right
now is do not worry about it.
You're not going to break your computer.
And we're going to go super
slowly through the steps and
explain what you're doing very
explicitly as you do each step.
That said,
sometimes students run into problems.
So I want to give you some additional
tools to help you resolve those issues.
If you do run into a problem,
I've got three resources for you.
First is the troubleshooting document,
linked in the instructor notes.
Second, is the forums and chat, where
you can ask fellow students for help.
I'll be checking in once in a while to
see what problems students are finding
and update the first
document accordingly.
So if you do happen to
solve your problem,
consider posting about your
experience in the forums.
When you're talking about an error,
it helps to copy the text of the error.
You can also take a screen shot of the
error by using the keys Ctrl+Cmd+Shift
on the Mac or
the screenshot key on a Windows machine.
Finally, when I run into errors,
I often Google them.
Nine times out of ten, you're going to
immediately find somebody who's run into
the exact same error that you have.
And by the power of the Internet,
a lot of people are going to
have come together and
help them resolve that error.
So you can follow the exact same
steps that they've followed
to resolve your problem.
Now if you're trying to figure
out what to actually search with.
My suggestion is to copy the error
message that you're getting and
add a word like Java or or
Android studio to the end of it.
Okay.
Let's dive in.